how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we got a really awesome leak for
Avengers in game that gives us proof and
basically confirms something that we've
been speculating and theorizing about
ever since the Russo brothers uploaded
this cryptic photo to Instagram and
Twitter and that is that war machine
will wield the proton cannon which is a
massive weapon that he has in Marvel vs.
Capcom in Avengers in game also a
reminder that I started a new giveaway
I'm giving away 5 imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Captain
Marvel or Avengers in-game if you'd like
to interfere your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
character that could be a superhero or a
villain so many months ago the Russo
brothers posted this cryptic photo to
Instagram with a caption look hard this
sent the internet into a frenzy and
everybody started to look and try to
figure out what we're supposed to find
in this photo at the time we didn't know
that Avengers 4 would be called Avengers
in game we did not have the title yet so
a lot of people thought that the title
could be in this photo
but there were many people that saw this
machine on the left and thought that it
could be the proton cannon that war
machine has then one fan noticed that
this machine is actually in Avengers
infinity war at the Avengers facility
and we see it when Rhodey is talking to
Ross so many people got on board
believing that this could be the proton
cannon because it does look a lot like
it from Marvel vs. Capcom well today we
got a new toy leaked that shows more
machine with brand new armor and a
massive gun as you can see in this photo
in the top left war machine has his
normal gun that he wields on his
shoulder but as you can see in the
bottom left he has a new massive weapon
and the Avengers logo on the packaging
actually cuts off some of the weapon as
well so it's bigger than it looks as you
can see it's huge if you compare it to
war machines arms that are even more
buffed up in this armor as well it's
still way bigger and although it doesn't
look exactly like the proton cannon in
Marvel vs. Capcom you can see that it's
clearly a massive weapon that mounts on
his shoulder just like the proton cannon
does and it's also probably
much bigger in the movie this figurine
is probably not to scale and even the
Russo brothers just came out and said
that most of the time these toy leaks
aren't exactly 100 percent accurate not
meaning that they're fake
just that they aren't 100 percent the
same as they are in the movie so even
though this weapon is huge and much
bigger than his arm is and it needs a
shoulder mount to wield I still think
that it's going to be much bigger in the
movie as you can see war machine
definitely has an armor upgrade he's
much more bulky and it looks like he has
a lot more power to his armor now so
obviously getting a weapon upgrade such
as the proton cannon with his armor
upgrade just makes sense so there you
have it a new toy leak that has war
machine with a massive weapon basically
confirming the fact that he wields a
proton cannon like weapon in Avengers
end game so let me know what you think
about war machine wielding this weapon
and getting an armor upgrade in Avengers
end game and what do you think did we
solve the Russo brothers cryptic photo
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything related to
Marvel and Avengers endgame as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]